ahora que ya sabemos la regla de
potencias la cual establece que la
derivada con respecto a x de x a la n es
igual a n por x a la n 1 esto para n
distinto de 0 creo que es importante
presentarte otras reglas propiedades y
conceptos que se aplican a las derivadas
las cuales básicamente nos van a
permitir derivar cualquier polinomio por
lo que te voy a proveer de herramientas
poderosas lo primero que quiero
considerar es porque este caso
particular en que n es distinto de cero
qué pasa si n es igual a cero veamos lo
tomemos entonces intentemos tomar
entonces la derivada con respecto a x de
x a la cero de x elevada a la potencia
cero entonces cuál es la derivada con
respecto a x de x a la cero y aquí
tenemos que suponer que x es distinto de
0 0 al acero produce cosas muy extrañas
entonces si x es distinto de 0 la
derivada con respecto a x de x a la 0 es
igual a la derivada con respecto a x de
1 x elevado a la potencia 0 es igual a 1
y cuál es entonces la derivada con
respecto a x
de uno bien para contestar esa pregunta
voy a graficar la función fx igual a 1
para hacer esto más claro aquí tenemos
entonces nuestro eje y nuestro eje
vertical y aquí estaría nuestro eje x el
eje horizontal
fx igual a 1 fx igual a 1 es simplemente
una recta horizontal que pasa por igual
a 1 esta de aquí es la función de igual
a fx igual a 1 y para calcular la
derivada de esta función recordemos que
la derivada es simplemente la pendiente
de la recta tangente entonces
consideremos cuál es la pendiente de
esta recta de esta recta horizontal
bueno al ser una recta la pendiente es
constante la pendiente no cambia y de
hecho la pendiente esta recta horizontal
es igual a cero pongámoslo por acá la
pendiente para todo punto sobre la recta
es igual a cero entonces si la pendiente
para todo punto es igual a cero la
derivada con respecto a x va a ser igual
a cero y esto es válido no tan solo para
la función constante igual a 1
para cualquier función constante
pongamos por ejemplo
3 esta es igual a 3 cuánto es para esta
función la derivada de ye con respecto a
x y observe entonces cómo estamos
introduciendo varias notaciones para la
derivada está la anotación de jane de x
la cual es equivalente a que prima y
cuánto es esta derivada bueno vemos aquí
que en esta recta la pendiente para todo
x es igual a 0 y por tanto la derivada
de ye con respecto a x que prima es
igual a cero así que no tan sólo para x
a la cero si tú tomas la derivada de
cualquier constante ésta va a ser igual
a cero escribamos esto la derivada con
respecto a x de a donde a es cualquier
constante esto es igual a cero como
puedes ver es una regla bastante
sencilla bien veamos otra propiedad
supongamos que queremos sacar la
derivada de una constante por una
función y voy a usar la misma letra a
para denotar la constante entonces si
queremos calcular la derivada con
xd a por fx esto a que va a ser igual
bueno esta regla nos dice que siempre
podemos sacar la constante de la
derivada es decir esto va a ser igual
a la constante y lo va a poner en el
mismo color magenta esto es igual a la
constante a por la derivada con respecto
a x la derivada con respecto a x de fx
de mi función f x lo ponen azul de fx y
esto esto también lo podemos escribir de
la siguiente manera esto va a ser igual
a la constante a y esta derivada con
respecto a x de fx es simplemente f
prima de x esto te puede parecer
notación un tanto extraña pero estoy
seguro que con el siguiente ejemplo te
va a quedar clara la regla
supongamos entonces que tenemos que
calcular la derivada con respecto a x d
por equis a la quinta deja de mantener
los mismos colores dos por equis a la
quinta bien la regla que acabamos de ver
que nos dice nos dice que la constante
la podemos sacar de la derivada entonces
va a ser 2 por la derivada con respecto
a x de x a la quinta por la derivada con
respecto a x de y como puedes ver
esencialmente lo que estamos haciendo es
sacar el 2 antes de la derivada entonces
esto va a ser igual a 2 por la derivada
con respecto a x de x a la quinta y como
derivamos x a la quinta bien por la
regla de potencias podemos calcular que
esto es 5x a la cuarta deja escribir
entre la constante 2 por la deriva de
quizá la quinta va a ser aquí tenemos la
regla 5 por equis a las 5 menos 1 x a la
cuarta 5 x x a la cuarta entonces esto
va a ser 2 por 5 por equis a la cuarta y
esto que va a ser igual multiplicamos
las constantes 2 por 5 10 x a la cuarta
que hicimos aplicamos aquí la regla de
potencias la derivada de quizá las 5 es
5 por equis a la cuarta
por dos nos dio 10x a la cuarta y eso
nos simplifica bastante las cosas ahora
ya podemos aplicar esta propiedad para
llevar cualquier función de la forma a
por equis a la n veamos ahora otra regla
estas reglas se aplican no tan sólo con
la regla de potencias sino para
cualquier función lo que sucede con la
regla de potencias es que usando la en
combinación con estas reglas podemos
derivar cualquier tipo de polinomio
entonces si queremos la derivada de una
suma de funciones digamos la derivada
con respecto a x de fx + gdx esto a que
es igual bueno para nuestra fortuna esto
es igual a la suma de las derivadas esto
es igual a efe prima de x deja de poner
lo mejor en notación de de en de equis
esto es igual a la derivada con respecto
a x de fx más la diva con respecto a x
gx vamos a escribirlo esta es la viva
con respecto a x de fx más la derivada
con respecto a x de gx y esto es igual
usando la otra anotación a la derivada
con respecto a x de fx que es f prima de
x
efe prima de x más la deriva con
respecto a x deje de x la diva con
respecto a x deje de x que es igual a g
prima de x de nueva cuenta esto puede
parecer como notación muy extraña para
ti pero ahora que hagamos el ejemplo te
va a quedar claro si tenemos por ejemplo
la derivada con respecto a x de digamos
x al cubo x al cubo más
x a la menos 4 esto a que va a ser igual
bueno veamos esta es la derivada de una
suma es igual a la suma de las derivadas
la derivada de x kubica ya sabemos que
es 3x cuadrada aplicando la regla de
potencia más la derivada de quizá la
menos 4 que es más menos 4 bajamos el
exponente bajamos el exponente menos
cuatro más menos 4 menos cuatro por
equis a la menos 4 - 1 - 5 por equis a
la menos 5 esto es igual al final de
cuentas a 3 x cuadrada
- 4x a la menos 5 y ahora ya contamos
con las herramientas para derivar
cualquier polinomio ya tenemos
herramientas para derivar cualquier tipo
de polinomio hagamos un ejemplo para
practicar esto
calculemos entonces la derivada con
respecto a x de fx supongamos que fx es
igual a 2x al cubo menos 7x cuadrada más
3x menos 7
y la derivada con respecto a x dfa que
va a ser igual
efe prima de x a que es igual bueno
empezamos aplicando nuestras reglas aquí
tenemos 2 por x cúbica la deriva de 2
por equis cúbica sacamos la constante
como vimos va a ser 2 por la deriva de x
kubica que es 3x cuadrada lo la derivada
de menos 7 x cuadrada deriva de menos 7
x cuadra es menos 7 la constante por la
elevada de x cuadrada que es 2 por x 12
por x luego más derivada de 3x esto es 3
por la derivada de x x es x a la 1
aplica hablar en la potencia sería 1 x x
a la 0 1 x x sala 0 es uno no lo
indicamos tan sólo queda 3 y finalmente
más la derivada de menos 100 y esto fue
lo que vimos al principio la derivada
déjame ponerlo en otro color para
distinguirlo la derivada de una
constante es igual a cero entonces esto
va a ser más la derivada de menos 100
que es igual a cero
bien simplifiquemos ahora esta expresión
para obtener entonces que la derivada de
f con respecto a x efe prima de x 2 x 36
x cuadrada menos 7 x 2 x menos 14 x más
30 no lo ponemos y ya hemos acabado ya
tenemos una gran diversidad de
herramientas que nos permiten encontrar
derivadas de polinomios